a very good evening to you we start with
some breaking news a second innocent
victim of violent crime over Christmas
has been named tonight Cody Fisher a
promising footballer was stabbed to
death in a Birmingham nightclub follows
the murder of Ellie Edwards a young
beautician shot dead in a merseyside pub
tonight Sky News has spoken to the
chairman of Stratford football club Jed
McCrory he was speaking to our
correspondent Becky Johnson
Cody Fisher was one of when I I came to
the club four years ago and Cody was one
of the first signings of the club he'd
just come out of Warsaw he's a talented
footballer but more importantly he was a
lovely person he was just a lovely naddy
cheeky smile on his face in that blonde
hair blue eyes he didn't have a bad bone
and I I said to you earlier that I know
people say that but he didn't he he
played football in the car part with the
kids he's just a great kid and everybody
knows everybody who's he's spoken to
some of the one of the young kids they
all know each other
it's going to be a hard one to take this
for everybody
everyone at this cabin was so well liked
cheers
just
anything we could do to help will do
I'm so sorry from
Sky's Becky Johnson is in Stratford upon
Avon this evening having spoken to there
the chairman of Cody's football club and
what else Becky are we learning this
evening about this very very sad uh case
and the victim himself
well you heard there and saw the emotion
the devastation that the death of 23
year old Cody Fisher was caused for his
the chairman of the football club here
in Stratford also his fellow players
they all know each other so well and
we've have also had a statement from a
family member a brief statement this
evening which said they've broken our
hearts I've lost my best friend my
family and I are asking for privacy and
respectfulness at this heartbreaking
times that's from a family member of
Cody Fisher this evening
um just shock disbelief people who knew
Cody he had many friends I've been
speaking to friends of his he was well
known within the footballing world in
the West Midlands because he played for
a number of local clubs they all say the
same thing that there wasn't a bad bone
in his body one of his friends who
played with him at Bronze Grove said
that they went on an end-of-season
holiday to Portugal last summer and he
said that he was the kind of friend who
would do anything for anyone and indeed
he was out with friends at the crane
nightclub up in Birmingham last night
just simply we're told by people who
know people who are there enjoying
himself on the Dance Floor just dancing
with the girls somebody said when he was
stabbed
um inexplicably people who know him say
they say that he just was such a lovely
young man and the police were called
about 11 45 this was just before this
big Club event was due to end and very
very sadly around half an hour later
Cody was pronounced dead we know that
one of his friends was also assaulted
but has now been released from hospital
so the police say that they are really
Keen to speak to anyone who was at that
club night we know from the club's own
social media that it would there were
hundreds of people on the dance floor it
was absolutely packed at the time I
spoken to a member of Staff who says it
was just Mayhem when this stabbing
happened people running out of that club
obviously scared when they heard what
had happened but the police say they
want to speak to anyone who was there
anyone who might have seen what happened
to anyone who might have been filming on
their phone around that time might have
some evidence that could help lead to
whoever did this in the meantime there
are reports from people who are at that
club night they do seem to describe they
say a group of lads who appeared to be
out looking for trouble of course that's
purely anecdotal the police really Keen
to see any footage any CCTV and hear
from anyone who might help them get to
whoever did this
Becky thanks man